THE SENANTE QUALITY
COMMITTEES TO ORDER
THOSE BILLS THERE YOU GO
-- I NOTICED THE THE
PRESENCE OF A QUORUM
-- FOR YOUR
GAMING OKAY DOING IT FOR
AT FOUR THIRTY
THIS EASTER EASTERN HERE
BOB
SO JUST REMIND FOLKS
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERAGE
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
WE'RE LIMITING NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS WERE HEARING TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES --
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY REMOTE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING TODAY
SO M. WILL
ALSO ORG PLEASE TO WELCOME
CENTER LEANING AND SALAS
TO ARGUE Q. COMMITTEE
FOR FOLKS
WHO WANT TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THAT THERE'S A TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
I WILL NOT SIT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6360 FOUR ACCESS CODE
IS. SIX FIVE FOUR TWO EIGHT
NINE SEVEN. SORRY IF WE COULD-
ESTABLISH A QUORUM CONSULTING
IF YOU COULD PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HERE. ALLEN HERE
BATES. A DOLLY DOLLY HERE
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HERE SKINNER.
STERN STERN HERE MICHALSKI. YES
OKAY SO WE DO HAVE A CORE WE
WILL OVERSEE THAT OUR
COLLEAGUES WILL BE ON THEIR WAY.
LETSON WE DO NEED TO DOCTOR
COMMITTEE RULES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL HAVE WE WILL
ADOPT THOSE RULES OKAY SO THE
COURT HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED OF
LET'S HEAR FROM OUR FIRST
AUTHOR SENATE MCGUIRE IS COULD
BE PRESENT IN THE ONE BILL
WE'RE HEARING TODAY SB SEVEN
THIS IS BY CENTER ATKINS. AND
THE SENATE MCGUIRE WILL BE
PRESENTING THE BILL TODAY SO WE
WELCOME YOU TO THE DIET SENATOR.
TO PRESENT SB SEVEN THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SAID GOOD
AFTERNOON HAPPY MONDAY AND
GRATEFUL TO BE WITH YOU MISTER
CHAIR SB SEVEN IS PRO TO
MACINNES LEGISLATION
LEGISLATION TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS OUR STATE'S AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS CAN GET
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY MOVING
AGAIN FROM THIS COMPANY INTO
RECEPTION THIS CRITICAL
LEGISLATION IT EXTENDS AND
EXPANDS PROVISIONS OF A SEQUEL
STREAMLINING STATUTE KNOWN AS
AB NINE HUNDRED. WHICH REDUCE
PAPERWORK AN EXPEDITED LEGAL
CHALLENGES TO LARGE MULTI
BENEFIT HOUSING ENERGY AND
MANUFACTURING PROJECTS SB SEVEN
EXTENDS THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SUNSET OF AB NINE HUNDRED
THROUGH THE END OF YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE FOR THE LARGER
PROJECTS COUNTRY COVERED UNDER
THE PRIOR LAW. BUT THIS
LEGISLATION WILL ALSO EXPAND
THE LAW TO APPLY STREAMLINING
TO MUCH SMALLER HOUSING
PROJECTS LOWERING THE THRESHOLD
OF QUALIFYING PROJECTS TO
FIFTEEN MILLION NOW THIS IS AN
85% REDUCTION IN REQUIRED
INVESTMENT OVER THE PRIOR LAW.
UNDER SB SEVEN HOUSING PROJECTS
ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE AT LEAST
15% 15% AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
BE INFILL PROJECTS AND THEY
NEED TO MEET THE SKILLED AND
TRAINED LABOR REQUIREMENTS IN
ELEVATED IN ELEVATED
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS NOW SB
SEVEN MAY APPEAR FAMILIAR TO
THIS COMMITTEE IN FACT THE VERY
SIMILAR BILL MOVE FORWARD LAST
YEAR SB NINE NINE FIVE THAT
PASSES COMMITTEE IT PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IN THE
SENATE FLOOR ON A BIPARTISAN
VOTE. SB NINE NINE FIVE ALSO
PASSED THE ASSEMBLY WITH OVER
SIXTY VOTES STRUCTURE MEMBERS
BUT UNFORTUNATELY FAILED TO
RETURN TO THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE VOTE BEFORE THE
SESSION EXPIRED THIS PAST
AUGUST NOW SINCE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN THEY NOW SUNSET AB NINE
HUNDRED HAS RESULTED IN
EXPEDITED APPROVAL NEARLY
TWENTY MAJOR NEW CLEAN ENERGY
AN INFILL PROJECTS. THAT
REPRESENTS TWO BILLION TWO
BILLION INVEST IN THE STATE AND
IN THOUSANDS OF NEW HOUSING
UNITS IN HIGH WAGE FAMILY
SUSTAINING JOBS. SB SEVEN.
HOUSING THAT EXPANSION WILL
ALSO BUILD UPON THE SUCCESS IN
RESERVE RESULT IN MORE HOUSING
AND JOBS IN CALIFORNIA WHEN WE
NEED IT MOST WHEN OUR ECONOMY
IS CHALLENGE. AB NINE HUNDRED
MODEL HAS BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL
THAT HAS BEEN REPLICATED IN
OTHER LARGE PRACTICAL DECISIONS
FROM THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE
GOLDEN ONE ARENA WHICH RESULT
IN AN ECONOMIC RENAISSANCE
RIGHT HERE IN DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTO. TO THE APPLE WORLD
HEADQUARTERS IN CORPORATE
CORPORATE TINO. A CUPERTINO IN
IT HAS A. 1-690-001-0080 SEVEN
JOBS. UNDER THE INFORMATION
FROM THE OFFICE A PLANE
RESEARCH. I AND OUR OWN SENATE
OFFICE RESEARCH PROJECTS
APPROVED UNDER THE AB NINE
HUNDRED PROCESS HAS PROVIDED
MORE THAN TEN. THOUSAND NEW
HOUSING UNITS. WITH THE
EXPANDED PROVISIONS OF SB SEVEN
WE CAN EXPECT MANY MORE HOUSING
UNITS TO BE TO USE THIS PROCESS
TO BE ABLE TO GET BILL. ALSO
CONSIDER THIS AB NINE HUNDRED
HAD ALSO WAS APPLIED
SUCCESSFULLY TO LARGE HOUSING
AN INFILL DEVELOPMENTS. FOR
EXAMPLE THE CROSSROADS
HOLLYWOOD PROJECT CREATES NINE
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN NEW
HOUSING UNITS. AT THE HOUSE THE
HOLLYWOOD CENTER PROJECT. EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO UNITS
WITH A HUNDRED THIRTY THREE OF
THOSE SLATED AS AFFORDABLE
SENIOR HOMES. THE PATERNAL
POWER STATION IN SAN FRANCISCO
IT'S A MIXED USE WATERFRONT
REVIVAL PROJECT THAT'S GOING TO
INCLUDE TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED TO
THREE THOUSAND YEARS HOUSING
UNITS. ALL UNDER THE AB NINE
HUNDRED FORMULA. IT PAST
EXPERIENCES IS ANY INDICATION
EXTENSION AND EXPANSION THE LAW
TO SMALLER HOUSING PROJECTS
THAT HAVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS WILL SIGNIFICANTLY HELP
WITH EXPERT EX EXPEDITED.
CONSTRUCTION IN. THE PROVISION
OF NEW HOUSING STARTS.
CALIFORNIA'S CONTINUED HOUSING
SHORTAGE IS A MAJOR STRAIN ON
THE STATE'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY
AND FUTURE AS WELL AS ON THE
GOLDEN STATE SOCIAL WELFARE.
MEDICAL AND PUBLIC SAFETY
SYSTEMS ARE STATE TO LOWER
INCOME FAMILIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE KOBLET. RECESSION IN AT A
GREATER RISK FOR HOUSING
INSTABILITY AND HOMELESSNESS AS
WELL AS LESSEN CHANCES FOR
UPWARD MOBILITY. SB SEVEN
OFFERS A STRATEGIC WAY TO
ADDRESS A HOUSING SHORTAGE BY
INCENTIVIZING PRODUCTION IN
EXPEDITING THE TIME FRAME FOR
ALL TYPES OF HOUSING TO BE ABLE
TO BE BUILT. SO MISTER MAYOR IT
IS- I'M GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE TO
BE HERE AGAIN PRESENTING ON
BEHALF OF PRO TEM ATKINS. BUT
WE DO HAVE A FEW FOLKS. WHO ARE
GOING TO BE SPEAKING HERE TODAY.
OBVERSES TO BE THE OF SAN JOSE
MISTER LICCARDO WE'RE REALLY
GREAT. FOR THE MAY HELP ON THIS
WE ARE SO APPRECIATIVE THAT
WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM ROBBIE
HUNTER WHO IS THE EXECUTIVE
FROM THE STATE BUILDING TRADES.
AS WELL AS- ALEXA ARENA WHO IS
THE DIRECTOR OF REAL ESTATE
DEVELOPMENT FOR GOOGLE ALL WILL
BE ON THE LINE FOR THE LEAD
WITNESSES. I JUST WANT TO SAY
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS AS WELL AS YOUR STAFF
THANK YOU SO MUCH RICHER. IT
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. YOU CENTER THANK YOU SO
MUCH OKAY SO WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO OUR THREE PRIMARY WITNESSES
THAT YOU MENTIONED I THINK
THEY'RE READY ON THE PHONE LINE.
TWO PRESENTS. PROVIDED BY THE
WAY IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
RICARDO I'VE BEEN EVERY THIS IS
HERE IN IN IN TO REPLACE ALL
ALEX ARENA. VISITORS ARE
PARTICULARLY LIKE THIS PERSON.
I THINK YOU HAVE A RESERVE THE
MAYOR THAN GO WITH MISTER
HUNTER AND GO GOVERNOR OKAY.
WONDERFUL HI MY NAME IS SAM
LICCARDO AND I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU- YOUR PERSONALITY. AND
EVERY MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE-
TAKING UP SENATE BILL SEVEN
EARLY IN THE SESSION. AND
SEVERAL YOU FOR YOUR PASSED
IMPORTED SB NINE NINE FIVE LAST
YEAR. I'M HEARING AN ECHO ARE
YOU ALSO HEARING ABOUT THEM.
YEAH WE HAD A CLEAR MISS
AMERICA. OKAY ONE OF ALL
PROCEED THAT. I DON'T LIKE TO
THINK I CAN I CAN FOR HER
AUTHORSHIP OF THIS LEGISLATION
HER LONGSTANDING LEADERSHIP
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- BY THE WAY
I'M GETTING FEEDBACK CANDIDATE
WE CAN HEAR YOU FINE BUT I
THINK THE LEAD WHICH I'M I'M
HEARING FROM OTHER I'M GETTING
MESSAGES FROM PEOPLE SAYING
THAT THE OTHER LEAD WITNESSES
NEED TO MUTE WHILE THEY'RE NOT
SPEAKING SO- SO IF THE OTHER TO
ME WITNESSES COMMUTE AND WHAT
WILL CONTINUE WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY MISTER MERRETT. THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU
MUCH MORE CLEAR. MY CITY IS
SEEN AS A IN SEVERAL OTHER
CITIES THAT HAD CERTIFIED AB
NINE HUNDRED PROJECT DELAYED BY
THE IMPACT OF THIS PANDEMIC AND
IS EXAMPLE. DOWNTOWN WEST
PROJECT ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE GOING
TO HEAR MORE FROM. OTHER
WITNESSES. BUT RISING MOST. UP
I DID A CURRENT BEST. YOU CAN'T
IN CALIFORNIA. YOU TWENTY
MULTIPLE CRIED MOTIONS.
COMPLAINING AFFORDABLE. MORE
THAN FORTY SOUTH HI ALL AT
LEAST 25% OF WHAT MUST BE. IN A-
I WOULD 9% I DON'T WHAT I.
GOOGLE IS CONSTRUCTING AN
ELECTED WHAT EXACTLY. FEET OFF.
HELLO AND THAT WILL PRODUCE.
ONE FIFTY SEVEN. CAN YOU.
COURSE A GOOD RESUME I WE WANT
TO YOU IN A BIT CONNECTION- SO
LET LET'S WHAT ONE OF MONEY SEE
IF YOU CAN GET A NEW BETTER
PHONE BECAUSE IT YOU'VE BEEN
CUTTING OUT QUITE A BIT LET'S
LET'S GO TO MISTER HUNTER I'LL
TRY IT AGAIN AND THE MAYBE YOU
CAN CALL BACK AND WE CAN TRY TO
WE CAN GET YOU IN AS YOUR OUR
THIRD WITNESS I APOLOGIZE I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE YOU WE
WERE ABLE TO HEAR TESTIMONY TO
WHAT WHEN WE GO TO YOU MISTER
HUNTER. THE WHOLE TIME SO WAS
NOT MADE. THANK YOU YOU MAY
PROCEED IT'S GOOD TO HEAR YOUR
VOICE. YOU WILL FIND IT VERY
MUCH- GERMAN CALLING FOR.
RICHARD TO SPEAK ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL- SB SEVEN- EARLY
AND ALL THE VERY BEST IN. THE
UNITED STATES COMMITTED CALL.
OF BUT THE MARGINS WERE ALL OUR
RESIDENTS NOT ONLY IN OUR
HEALTH WITH A LAWSUIT. ABOUT
FIFTY THOUSAND- PEOPLE. BUT
ALSO IN A CONDOMINIUM OF THE
LOS OF JOBS ARE STRANDED IN
HOME KIDS NOT BEING ABLE TO GO
TO SCHOOL AND- SB SEVEN
ISRAELIS SHOT IN THE ARM FOR
THE ECONOMY. MORALS PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THERE ARE
A ENVIRONMENTALLY- COMPATIBLE.
GEN TOWARDS A ARBITRARY
ENVIRONMENT PROVIDES ALL UNITS
MOVES A LOT LARGE. PROJECTS
WILL PROVIDE CARE WITH ON THE
JOB STROKES THE STATE. IT WILL
BE THIS ALONG. COMING MADE
COULD IN THE PROCESS TO HELL US
OUT THOSE- ROSE AS FAR AS
BECAUSE- WE SHARED THE HOTELS
TO WORK WERE NOT PERCENT ALL
EMPLOY. WE SEE IT- IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY AND- IN
AMERICA AND THE WILL. HER
MATERNAL TERRORISM REALLY ARE
GOING ON TO HAVE A SOME PLAN.
TO GET THE SIX BACK ON THE
STREET NATION WIDE BUT THE
TRIGGER CALIFORNIA. WHEN I
SELECT A LEGISLATORS FOR MOVING
THIS LEGISLATION WE TRY TO DO
IT LAST YEAR AND WE FELL SHORT.
AT THE END OF THE YEAR BUT-
THIS- SENATE MCGUIRE SAID THIS
IS VERY SIMILAR IF NOT ALMOST
IDENTICAL. TO LEGISLATION ON
THE PEOPLE COLLEGES WITH- LARGE.
MAJORITIES- I. HAVE OKAY SO FAR
HUNDRED WORKERS WE REPRESENT IN
THE ASSEMBLY. EIGHT THOUSAND
PRACTICES USED WHICH IS THE
MOST DIVERSE WORKFORCE IN THE
NATION IN CONSTRUCTION WE THANK
THIS COMMITTEE- FOR CONSIDERING
THIS BILL IN THE BANK. ARE
USING THE COULD SOUNDED FROM AS
SOON. TRYING TO HELP BOLSTER
NEWS- OKAY. ASIDE FROM THE WE
ARE AND I ASTRONOMICAL ALARM SB
SEVEN. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER HUNTER. OKAY WE'RE NEXT
CAN HEAR FROM RECORD OF IN
EVERY THIS WHO'S ACTUALLY
SPEAKING. IT IN INSTEAD OF
ALEXA RAN A FROM FROM FROM
GOOGLE I GUESS THERE WAS A
FAMILY EMERGENCY AND SO MISTER
MISTER IN EVERY THIS IS GOING
TO SPEAK. IN ALEXIS PLACE AND
THEN WILL HERE- AFTER THAT-
HOPEFULLY FROM THE MAYOR. THANK
YOU THIS IS A PART ONLY GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHALLENGED BY
SURVEYS AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO APPEAR BEFORE
YOU TODAY YEAH GLOBAL STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL SEVENTY.
MY NAME IS A KIND OF AN OBVIOUS
AND I AM A DIRECTOR. WITHIN THE
GLOBAL MARKET DEVELOPMENT TEAM.
IT WAS FOUNDED IN CALIFORNIA IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AND TODAY
HAS MORE THAN FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS A
PROPOSED DOWNTOWN WEST
EXPANSION PROJECT IN THE CENTER
OF SAN JOSE. DOWNTOWN WHAT IT
IS EXACTLY WHAT. THE PROJECT-
INTENDED TO DO ONE LEGISLATION
WAS PASSED AROUND EIGHTY NINE
HUNDRED. MANY PUBLIC BENEFIT
THE CORPORATE INTO THIS PROJECT
ARE MADE POSSIBLE BECAUSE OF
THE EXPEDITED REVIEW AND
CERTAINTY THAT EIGHTY NINE
HUNDRED- ALLOWS FOR. MANY
BRIEFLY DISCUSS SOME OF THE KEY
BENEFITS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CURRENT PROPOSED PROJECT.
PROJECTS INCLUDES. FOUR
THOUSAND HOUSING UNITS WITHIN
ONE HALF MILE OF THE DEER DOWN
STATION WHICH IS. SLATED TO BE
THE LARGEST TRAIN STATION WEST
OF THE MISSISSIPPI. ALTHOUGH
FOUR THOUSAND UNITS 25% OF
THOSE UNITS WILL BE AFFORDABLE
REPRESENTING ONE OF THE LARGEST
PROGRESS OF ITS KIND IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. WITH THE HOUSE
INCOMES THAT JOBS. AND WE ARE
PROPOSING SEVEN POINT THREE
MILLION SQUARE FEET OF
COMMERCIAL OFFICE DEVELOPMENT
WILL BE CRITICAL TO SOUND DAY
IN THE STATE'S OVERALL ECONOMIC
VITALITY. OF THE JOBS WITHIN
THE PROJECT THAT'S TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND FULL TIME JOBS
ASSOCIATED WITH- SIX WITHIN
SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION
SQUARE FEET AS WELL AS SEVENTY
FIVE HUNDRED AVAILING WAGE
CONSTRUCTION JOBS AND WE KNOW
THERE'S THOUSANDS MORE WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT THE INDIRECT JOBS
THAT A PROJECT OF THIS SIZE
COULD CREATE. THIS REPRESENTS
BILLIONS AND TOTAL ECONOMIC
OUTPUT INCLUDING OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS IN CONSTRUCTION LABOR
COSTS ALONE. IN ORDER TO CREATE
A GREAT PLACE WHILE ALSO
ALLOCATING FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET OF GROUND
FOR ACTIVE USERS FROM RETAIL TO
RESTAURANT SPECIFICS MASONS.
THEY CAN BE SHARED BY NONPROFIT
SMALL WOMEN MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES. WE'RE ALSO LOOKING
AT- PRESERVATION AND
RESTORATION OF THE HISTORIC
RESOURCES THAT ARE LOCATED
WITHIN THE PROJECT MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE HISTORIC RESOURCES
ARE COMING SERVING FIRST. WE
ARE IN THE CENTER OF DOWNTOWN
SAN JOSE BUT THERE'S ALSO THIS
INCREDIBLE URBAN ECOLOGY AS
PART OF OUR EIGHTY ACRE
DEVELOPMENT FOR ALLOCATING
FIFTEEN ACRES TO PARKS FATHERS
IN OPEN SPACES INCLUDING
RESTORATION OF SOME OF THE
RIGHT PAIRING NATURAL HABITAT
EXIST ALONG THE LOS GATOS
CREEK. AND MORE IMPORTANTLY AND
ALIGNED TO EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED
THE PROJECT WILL PRODUCE NET
ZERO CARBON EMISSIONS. IN
DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
GOVERNMENT THE GOVERNOR NEWSOM
CERTIFIED APART THE PROJECT
MEETING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERSHIP CONDITIONS ABOVE AB
NINE HUNDRED. LAST YEAR GIVEN.
COVERED IN SOME OF THE-
LIMITATIONS THAT MEANS ANOTHER
PUBLIC FARMS THE CITY COUNCIL
DID NOT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REVIEW AND HOPEFULLY APPROVED
OUR PROJECT. BUT THEY NINE
HUNDRED- REQUIRED OF THE LOCAL
AGENTS CERTIFIED THE PROJECT
JANUARY. TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SB
SIX IT'S CRITICAL THAT WOULD
THIS FALL BANKS THE- THAT ONLY
ASIAN. ACTIVE PROJECT RESEARCH
BY THE GOVERNOR UNDER THE TERMS
OF AB NINE HUNDRED. SHUFFLE
YOUR QUESTION SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN THE BILL CRITICAL TO
ALLOWING GOOGLE SUPPOSED
DOWNTOWN WAS PARTY TO MOVE
FORWARD ON SCHEDULE BRING JOBS
AND HOUSING FINANCE BASED
RECOVERING ECONOMY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR IMAGE SENSOR BUT EVERY
THIS OKAY WHAT'S NEXT HERE
GIVING ME THE MAYOR BACK UP ON
A- GUN A GOOD LINE. AND THANK
YOU CHALLENGE. HOPE YOU CAN
HEAR ME NOW. THANK YOU CHIRLA
BYE SIR BATES AND EVERY MEMBERS
COMMUNITY COMMITTEE THANK YOU
FOR TAKING UP SENATE BILL SEVEN
EARLY IN THE SESSION AND OF
COURSE YOUR PAST SUPPORT OF SB
NINE NINE FIVE LAST YEAR. IN
FORGIVE ME IF THIS IS
REPETITIVE BUT I UNDERSTAND
MUCH OF WHAT I SAID COULDN'T BE
HEARD SELL TRY THIS ONE MORE
TIME I JUST WANT TO THANK COACH
OF BACKING FOR HER AUTHORSHIP
THIS LEGISLATION AND A BROADER
LEADERSHIP AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- YOU KNOW MIKE HAS
ALREADY BEEN SAID SO I WON'T AT
LEAST HOPEFULLY I WON'T BE
REPEATING A LOT OF WHAT YOU'VE
HEARD- BUT CERTAINLY MORE
EXCITED LITTLE FOR THE DOWNTOWN
WEST PROJECT PARTNERSHIP WITH.
GOOGLE ARE BUILDING TRADED MANY
OTHER PARTNERS OUT WE BELIEVE
THIS COMPRISES THE MOST ONE OF
THE MOST IMPACTFUL AND BROADLY
BENEFICIAL PRIVATE SECTOR
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY HAVE BRUNCH MANY OF
CALIFORNIA'S MULTIPLE CRISES IF
YOU'VE HEARD CERTAINLY RUN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. CERTAINLY
AROUND EMPLOYMENT I THINK IT
ALSO NOTE THAT AMID THIS
CLIMATE CRISIS IS URBAN BILL IT
WILL MAXIMIZE THE HIGHEST
POTENTIAL CAN'T BE. AROUND OUR
DOWNTOWN CENTRAL STATION THE
SERVICE WILL BE SERVING IN JUST
A MATTER OF YEARS COUPLE YEARS
SERVING SEVEN MAJOR TRANSIT
SYSTEMS PART CALTRAIN EAST
CAPITAL QUARTER VGA LIGHT RAIL
BUS RAPID TRANSIT AND HOPEFULLY
WHEN IT ARRIVES HIGH SPEED
RAIL- YEAH THIS IS ALL BEING
CONSTRUCTED AT B. GOLD
STANDARD. WITH MAGNERO
GREENHOUSE. GAS EMISSIONS AND
DEVELOPMENT. FIFTEEN ACRES OF.
AND SPACE SO. PRECISE WHAT. THE
AUTHOR. OF THE NINE HADN'T.
WHEN THEY WERE ACROSS THE BILL
AND SCALE THAT IS INCREDIBLY.
AND HAS EXPANDED EXACT. OUR OUR
STATE STARK ECONOMIC DIVIDE.
DOWNTOWN WEST PROJECT WILL LIST
OF HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN. BENEFITS PROPERTY.
AROUND ANTI DISPLACEMENT JOB
TRAINING EDUCATION HOMELESSNESS
SOLUTION A HOST OF OTHER.
CRITICAL NEEDS AND SO WE HOPE
THAT WITH THIS BODIES APPROVAL
UNDERSCORE THE ASSEMBLY IN THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE ABLE TO BRING.
THIS DOWNTOWN WEST PROJECT FOR
MY COUNCIL'S CONSIDERATION MAY
WELL HAVE SHOVELS IN THE
GROUND. SOON THEREAFTER- THEY
JUST COULD NOT BE A ONE NEEDED
TIME FOR THE MOST
TRANSFORMATIVE. AND HISTORY OF-
THE LARGEST CITY IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND I DEEPLY
APPRECIATE WHATEVER EXTENT AT
YOU MIGHT SHARE A SENSE OF
URGENCY. I REALLY WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR KIND OF
LEADERSHIP IN THIS HISTORIC
DEEPLY. CHALLENGING BALTIC I
THANK YOU SENATE MCGUIRE FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD. AND
I. STAND READY FOR ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN APPRECIATE
THAT APPRECIATE THAT OKAY. SO I
NOW ANDERSON WE THIS THE OP TO
MOVE ON TO OTHER FOLKS WOULD
LIKE TO OUR TO GIVE US THEIR
THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL- I'D
LIKE TO REMIND EVERYBODY THAT
WE DON'T HAVE ANY LISTED
OPPOSITION AND THERE'S IN IRAQ-
I THINK FROM BOTH. SIDES OF THE
AISLE- SOAP SO PLEASE- WE'RE
ONLY ASKING YOU. FOR YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION. AND IF OTHERS
HAVE ALREADY. MADE SIMILAR.
REPRESENTATIONS ON BEHALF OF
THE WE HAVE A SOLUTION THAT YOU
HAVE PLEASE DO CONSIDER- BUT IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME- KEEPING
IT SHORTER OR BOARD FOR
DECLINING FROM FROM SPEAKING
OUT OBVIOUSLY WE WANT WE WANT
WE DO WANNA GET ONE AFTER JUST
TO CONCLUDE WOULD LIKE TO. SO
LET'S OPEN UP THE LINES LET'S
BEGIN I DON'T BELIEVE YOU
ANYWAY THIS IS HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. I SEE I'M
LOOKING AT THE VIDEO OF ONE
TWELVE AND DOESN'T BECAUSE OF
THOSE ANYONE THERE. SO THAT
MEANS THAT WE GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. HI SAMATAR WITH YOU
PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS WITHIN
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN WE WILL BEGIN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND WE
HAVE ABOUT THIRTY IN THE QUEUE
AT THE MOMENT WE'LL START WITH
NINE ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING THIS IS
JUSTIN ARE WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE ARE
PROUD TO SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU. NEXT SOME OF TO ONE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ADAM
REGULARLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ALSO PROUD
TO SUPPORT STILL HAPPY TO THE
PROGRAM- REDUCE IT THANK. NEXT
TWO ONE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL I MEMBERS MITCHELL
BATTLE WITH LOCAL ONE EIGHTEEN
IRONWORKERS WITHSTANDING THE
POOR WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES. THANK YOU. MAXIMO
CAROLINE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
RON MILLER WITH THE L. A.
ORANGE COUNTY BUILDING YOUR
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ON
BEHALF OF OUR HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND FORTY A
LOCAL UNIONS WE STAND WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES. IN
MAXIMO TIMELINE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JEFF ROBERTS
REGIONAL DIRECTOR WITH DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN LOCAL UNION TO
NINETY FOUR THEIR NATIONALLY
IMPAIRS KNOWLEDGE TRADE. AND
STRONG SUPPORT WITH THE BILLING
ST. MAXIMO CAROLINA ONE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
RECOGNIZE THEM WITH IBEW LOCAL
FIVE SIX NINE CALLING ACROSS
THE BOARD THANK YOU. MAXIMAL TO
LINE ONE NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MORE TOP ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT. BUT WHAT. WELL I KNOW
I DON'T EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DESTROYED A CHURCH LOW
REPRESENTING CREATORS ARE
BRINGS YOUR LOOK THREE SEVEN
SIX. REPRESENTING AND SOLANO
COUNTIES AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. MAXIMO TIELINE ONE GO.
JIM OUR BUSINESS MANAGER
SECRETARY OF INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS LOCAL FORTY RIGHT KERN
COUNTY AND WE ARE JOINING THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN THANK YOU.
MAXIMO CAROLINA ONE HUNDRED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS THE
CARPENTERS UNION LOCAL TWO
SEVENTEEN SAN MATTEO COUNTY WE
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL SEVEN. MAXIM OF
JULY NO ONE NO ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON ABOUT TWO
GAMES INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL
NUMBER TWELVE WE STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
ALONG WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES. MAXIM OF CAROLINA ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON ROB STOKER
REPRESENTING SHEET METAL
WORKERS LOCAL ONE OH FOUR AND
WE STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN ALONG WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES. SOME OF TO
LINE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MIKE WEST
REPRESENTING INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES. WE STAND IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN ALONG WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES THANK YOU. NEXT
SOME OF THE LINE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. STEPHEN BOOKER
IBEW LOCAL SIX SEVENTEEN OF
THEM UNTIL COUNTY WE'VE BEEN A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE SEVEN
WITH OUR SISTERS AND BROTHERS
FROM THE STATE BUILDING TRICKS
THANK YOU. MAXIMO WHY NO ONE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. TOM
LEVINSON DIEGO BUILDING TRADES
STILL SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN ALONG
WITH. THE STATE BUILDING TRADES.
MAXIM OF TIELINE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
HAPPENING THIS YEAR SO WHAT
LOCAL SIXTEEN HEAT IN COSTUMES
LETTERS I'M STANDING SHOWING
SUPPORT WHAT THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES THANK YOU. MAXIMO
CAROLINA ONE OH FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHEN MEMBERS KATIE
DONAHUE DURAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
NEIGHBORS SUPPORT. MAXIMO KLEIN
ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS THIS PAUL BAUER ON
BEHALF OF ONE HIGHWAY ONE IN
SUPPORT OF. SENATE BILL SEVEN
BY CENTER. MAXIM OF THE LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING KEVIN FERREIRA
REPRESENTING THE SECOND WAS
HERE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL AND WE STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
ALONG WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES THANK YOU. MAXIMO TO
LINE TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME THE BREAD
DAVIS WOULD DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN GLAZERS LOCAL UNION
SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE IN SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA AND WE STAND WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES AND
THEIR STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN. IN MAXIMO CAROLINE ONE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEERING MEMBERS
JOHN DOUGHERTY IBEW LOCAL SIX
IN SAN FRANCISCO WE STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. SEVEN
WITH OUR PARTNERS IN THE STATE
OF THE LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
DERREN COMPTON WESTERN REGION
REPRESENTATIVE WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
BRICKLAYERS AND ALLIED CRAFT
WORKERS STANDING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN ALONG WITH
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES. SOME OF
THE LINE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
BENITO ROBINSON WITH THE VOTE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
COUNCIL OF LABORERS AND WE'RE
JOINING STATE BUILDING TRADES
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF. SENATE
BILL SEVEN THANK YOU. MAXIMO
DI<c.cyan> ONE OH FOUR PLEASE GO</c>
AHEAD. CHARLES RIGHT
REPRESENTING FUNDS THAT THE
WILCOXON SUPPORT OF THE C.
SEVEN THANK YOU MEMBERS. MAXIMO
TIMELINE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS MARK BOOK FROM IBEW LOCAL
FIVE NINE FIVE REFUSING ALAMEDA
COUNTY WE ARE STRONG SUPPORTER
SB SEVEN THANK YOU. MAXIMO
CAROLINE ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
WILLIAM ARTHUR BURKE WITH WHITE
HOUSE PUBLI AFFAIRS ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA YIMBY THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA PLANNING AND
URBAN RESEARCH ASSOCIATION
OPENNESS FOR HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA AND CAN
HELP PROPERTIES IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN. NAG SOME OF THE LINE
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS JOHN SPALDING
REPRESENTING THE KERN INYO AND
MONO COUNTY BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL AND WE STAND IN THE
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES. IN SUPPORT OF
SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU. THE MOST
FOR TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS JEFF HONOR LOG
SECRETARY TREASURER THE HUMBLE
DEL NORD BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES WE STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT SB SEVEN WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES THANK
YOU. MAXIMO TIME FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
COUNCIL MY NAME IS EDDIE PINON
THE BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVE FOR
HEATING PROJECTS LEADERS EMPIRE
STOPPERS LOCAL FARMERS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA WE STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BEACH SB SEVEN.
FINISAR'S WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES THANK YOU.
THANK SOME OF THE LINE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
GLENN LEVEL OF IRONWORKERS
UNION LOCAL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
STANDING INSTRONG SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES THANK YOU.
MAXIMO TIME THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS WILLIAM
THEN DOLLARS WITH DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PATTERSON
BRIDEWELL FINISHERS LOCAL FORTY
SEVEN AND WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES AND THEIR
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN.
MAXIMO CAROLINE NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL I NINETY
NINE YOU MAY BE NEEDED. HELLO
MY NAME IS WIRED STYLES HELLO
ON BEHALF OF THE LOCAL PRE
NINETY EIGHT PLUMBERS INSTINCT
CENTERS- REPRESENTING OVER A
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND FAMILIES
WE WOULD LIKE TO. EXPRESS
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB. SEVEN
MAXIM OF TELLING FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS A
CHRIS MATTER WITH THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE
EXPRESSING STRONG SUPPORT FOR
SB SEVEN INSTEAD OF THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES THANK YOU.
MAXIMO CAROLINE FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK SOME OF
THE LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BRIAN HOGUE IBEW LOCAL FOUR TO
A TO BAKERSFIELD JOINING THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN. MAXIMO I
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS RJ FERRARI LOCAL THIRTY
PLUMBER SAN FRANCISCO WE ARE
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. MAXIM
OF THE LINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS PAUL
MARINO AMADORI WORKERS LOCAL
FOUR THIRTY THREE LOS ANGELES
AND- WE'RE JOINED THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN THEIR STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN THANK YOU.
MAXIM TO LINE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GLAD- COMMITTEE JEFFREY
OR MAKE IT LOOK A LOT FIVE
POINT NINE BUSINESS MANAGER WE
STAND WITH US STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN SUPPORT STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN. THANK YOU.
MAXIM OF THE LINE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. VISIT FOR
TOMORROW AT THE CEMENT MASONS
LOCAL FOUR HUNDRED AND WE'RE
STRONG SUPPORT- WITH SB. SEVEN
SEVEN IS STANDING WITH THAT
BUILDING TRADES. THANK YOU
MAXIM OF CAROLINA ONE TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. RAINY
ROLL WITH AN ALLY TRADE LOCAL
POKER SEVEN FOUR COMING OUT OF
SACRAMENTO AND WE STAND STRONG
SUPPORT WITH STATE BUILDING
TRADES SB. SEVEN MAXIMO MY
NINETY EIGHT BILLION BAHT HAD.
WELL I NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO YEAH. I WAS TOLD
NINETY SIX THIS IS RICK
CILIATES REPRESENTING
CARPENTERS LOCAL FOUR OH FIVE
IN SAN JOSE WE STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN.
THANK YOU. MAXIMO CAROLINE
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REAL WORLD GO HERE WITH THE
CEMENT MASONS LOCAL FOUR
HUNDRED WE STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THE SB SEVEN ALONG WITH THE
STATE BILL BEFORE IT. MAXIMO TO
LINE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS ORANGE
COUNTY WE STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN. MAXIMO TO
LINE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL I
HAD. HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN
CLEESE REGIONAL DIRECTOR
DESPICABLE SIXTEEN GLAZERS
LOCAL SEVEN SIX SEVEN
SACRAMENTO WE STAND STRONG
SUPPORT BUT THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES ON SB SEVEN. MAXIMO THE
LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAMARO MODERATES HAD CRUZ
COUNTY BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL WE STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT SB SEVEN AND THE
STATE BUILDING DURING. NEXT THE
MOTEL I NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON ARGUED
BELGIUM WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS REGIONAL
COUNCIL WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB SEVEN AN URGENT HIGH
VOTE THANK YOU. MAXIMO TIELINE
ONE ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
NOT THE CHAVEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
THANK YOU. MAXIM OF CAROLINA
ONE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
WILL SMITH AND BYBEE W. LOCAL
THIRTY THREE TWO. REPRESENTING
SANTA CLARA COUNTY. IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB SEVEN THANK YOU.
SOME OF THE LINE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GUARD. FOSTER CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JAMES POSSIBLE HELP
SIXTEEN LOCAL SEVEN FORTY ONE
HE SPENDS ALL SUPPORT WHAT THE
BUILDING TRADES ON SENATE BILL
SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MAXIMO TO LINE A ONE TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS IS CAROL CAN
THE SAN DIEGO BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
FAMILY HOUSING CORPORATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT SB SEVEN
ALONGSIDE. MONTEL MOTOR LINE
ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHARE MEMBERS SO THE- FERRARI
ON BEHALF OF FACEBOOK IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MAXIM OF THE
LINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CAN LENDS PLATINUM
ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF THE
HOLLYWOOD CENTER PROJECT AND WE
SUPPORT SB SEVEN. MAXIM OF THE
LINE ONE OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS BERNADETTE
PARKWAY ON BEHALF THE UNITED
NATION OF PALMERTON THEME THAT
THERE'S LOCAL UNION TO THIRTY
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK OUR
SENATOR TONI ATKINS DOWN HERE
IN SAN DIEGO FOR THE
LEGISLATION AND MOVING HOUSING
FORWARD WE'D LIKE TO SUPPORT.
SB SEVEN. AND MAC SILVA MOVED
TO ONE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
WELCOME TO SHARE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION-
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
THANK YOU. AND AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN ONE THEN
ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT. AND AT
THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
ELSE TO MAKE YOU. ARE THEY DO
SO MUCH MATTER. ALL RIGHT NOW I
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY GO TO
THOSE FOLKS WHO WANT TO RAISE
CONCERNS OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL- I DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE
ANY LEAD WITNESSES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINES YOU WANT TO
RAISE CONCERNS. MODERATOR. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO UPHOLD PRESS ONE BEEN
THERE ON NOW AGAIN TO OPPOSE
LONDON ZERO NOW. AND IT'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT. WE'LL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH THEY JUST STARTED YOUR
SOLUTION INSTRUCTORS IN THIS
LOCAL PARK LOS ANGELES ON
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THENAGAIN MATHIS TO UPHOLD
NEXT LEVEL TO LINE ONE OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ZERO TWO ONE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EVENING CHAIR MEMBER OF TRIPLE
KILL OFF ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF BEVERLY HOLD BE A POLITICS
THE MISSION. BOB I SPEAK THAT
ON THE BATTLEFIELD DURING IN
THERE THAT REQUIRING 250% OF
THE UNITS AND I HI TO BE ASIDE
AS A FOR UNITS TO MY- AND IF
YOU TO AS PART OF MY- THE JOHN
LAUGHTER MEASURE- AND WE
REQUEST AND AN AMENDMENT COULD
BE- CAN CREEP IN A REQUIRED FOR
THE- UNITS I THINK THE CALL THE
INTRODUCED WITHOUT THE- WE-
REQUEST THE LAST YEAR WE- A
RISK. FOR RESPECTFULLY ADOPT
AND FOR THE ON THE MEASURE WE
LOOK TWENTY WITH THE AUTHOR
OFFICE THANK YOU. AND AGAIN TO
A- PRESS ONE AND THEN THERE ARE
NOW. AGAIN. ZERO TWO. AND AT
THIS TIME WE DO NOT SHOW ANYONE
IN THE QUEUE. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH HARDER ARE YOU QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBERS
DESCRIPTION. THANK YOU WANNA
REYES. PARSER MCGUIRE DO A
CLOSE. CHAIR VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO EACH OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND MISTER
CHAIR WANT TO SAY A SPECIAL
THANKS TO YOU AT THE CHAIR HAS
BEEN VERY SINCERE IN HIS
DIALOGUE LEADING INTO TODAY'S
HEARING THERE'S BEEN SEVERAL
CONVERSATIONS I JUST WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO BE A BIG
KNOWLEDGE THAT CHAIR ON FOR HIS
WORK ON THIS BILL. THE PTT THE
PRO TEN HAS BEEN WORKING HARD
WITH ALL SIDES ON THIS BILL FOR
THE PAST TWO YEARS AT CENTER
GONZALEZ IS VERY FAMILIAR WITH
THIS IS A MEMBER OF THE HOUSING
WORKING GROUP- IN THIS IS A
SINCERE EFFORT TO HELP GET OUR
ECONOMY MOVING FROM THIS COVERT
INDUCED RECESSION AND BILL
DESPERATELY NEEDED HOUSING BOTH
MARKET RATE ITS WELLS
AFFORDABLE THAT WILL BENEFIT
GENERATIONS OF WORKING
FAMILIES. AND FINALLY MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THE AFFORDABILITY ISSUE THAT
WAS ADVANCED BY THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM BEVERLY
HILLS IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT
OUT THAT THE 15% THAT IS
EMBEDDED WITHIN THE BILL IS
SIMPLY A MINIMAL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IF THEY CHOOSE TO
GO ABOVE AND BEYOND- THAT 15%
BUT IT SIMPLY SETS A BASEMENT
BUT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE MORE
THAN WELCOME TO BE ABLE TO
EXPAND THAT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AT WITHOUT ANY FURTHER ADO ON
BEHALF OF PROTEIN MECHANISM
STRUCTURE THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
ALL OF YOUR WORK. WHAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER. TO
DECEMBER A HAVE A MOST FROM
CENTER GONZALEZ- ON SB SEVEN SO
AS TO MOVE A CINEMA TO THE
CONSULTANT THE MOTIONS TO PASS
REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. CONCERN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE ITEM NUMBER ONE
SB SEVEN BY SENATOR ATKINS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ALLEN FIVE. ALLEN HI
BATES I'M GONNA BE NO NOT
BUILDING JUST N THIS COMMITTEE
BECAUSE I GOT A LATE
COMMUNICATION I THINK OF
CONFUSED FROM UP FROM THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ALSO OBSCENE TODAY
BUT IT'LL BE COMING YEAR PROBES
RIGHT. I CAN GET SOME
CLARIFICATION SO I AM
ANTICIPATING TODAY THANK YOU.
URBEATS ABSTAINING DOLLY. DOLLY
I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I SKINNER
STERN BY CAL SKI. MY COUNTY
HIGH OKAY- I KNOW CENTERS
SKINNER HAS ASKED THAT WE KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN I AM. EARLY LEAD
TO A PANEL DISCUSSION. I WAS
WONDER IF I COULD PASSED TE-
THE GAVEL TO EITHER ARE PRICED
ARISE GERRARD GERMANOS- IF YOU
OR OR WE COULD ALSO RECONVENE
LATER- HI YOU CAN COME BACK IN
ABOUT HALF AN HOUR. FOR THE
SENATORS. FOUR THAT I DO
BELIEVE IT'S HERE SKINNER
SHOULD BE HERE SHORTLY SO WHO
WOULD BE POSSIBLE TO HAVE- THE
VICE CHAIR. AGAIN NEVER WANNA
VOLUNTEER ADAM UNIBODY MISTER
CHAIR BUT- I KNOW THAT- SERVICE
CATERS IN OUR OFFICE EVEN AS WE
SPEAK. OKAY ALL RIGHT WITH YOUR
WITH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FEEDBACK THANK YOU FOR THAT
MISS MINIMIZER. FOR THERE THANK.
YOU KNOW I DON'T IF YOU'RE
PRESENTING BILL. YEAH BECAUSE I
DON'T HAVE IT ON MY- YEAH. WE
ARE.
THE FALL ROLE. HI YEAH-
AND THEN. YEAH. FOR ABOUT A
MONTH. YES. THUNDERSTORMS COULD
BE HERE TO. CORRECT YEAH.
OKAY
WELCOME. OKAY TO MADAM
SECRETARY WHERE YOU LIVE THE
CALL IN SB SEVEN. I DON'T WANT
FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR HAPPENS
RUSSIAN IS DO YOU HAPPEN TO BE
THE FIRST THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE THE CURRENT POPE IS
FOUR ZERO WITH. THE LONG YEAH-
YEAH OF. SO THE CURRENT. I'M
SORRY THE STATE THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING TO CALL ON LIFTING A
CALL ON OUR ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
SEVEN BY SENATOR ATKINS AND-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ITEM ONE SB
SEVEN BY SENATOR ATKINS THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSING RE REFER
TO THE COME TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING HI IN THE VICE
CHAIR OF STAINING- SKINNER.
STERN FIVE STERN I. THE BILL IS
FIVE ZERO. DEFINITELY AND THAT
IS. FIVE TWO ZERO. THE CLOSER
ROLE AND ON THE MOTION IS TO
MOVE. TO IT'S GOING TO
APPROPRIATIONS. APPROVED I MEAN
I'M OUT OF I'M OUT OF THE- AND
THE THING IS A DETERRENT.